got a date with Star Wars this evening
so what Star Wars holy [ __ ] face it's
December 15th already that was that was
the most crazy thing that has ever
happened can we go see Star Wars what a
vlog Lando is here now guest starring
here in Chattanooga flew into Atlanta
this morning on a 6:00 a.m. flight did a
bunch of meetings with one of our
clients Mickey and I did two-hour drive
to a bunch of calls the westin the new
fancy hotel here in Chattanooga for a
bunch of meetings and the Chattanooga
holiday party is tonight
[Music]
yep do a podcast whatever see welcome
hey don't hey man how are you boys bro
like I don't think people get it
like what like it's just like it's it's
it's oxygen it's all-encompassing I want
to interact with we all love interacting
with a computer
the passive nature of the consumption
which means that equates into time
savings and my belief that time is the
number one variable asset that we
continue to gravitate towards even more
than money probably other than health
the most important thing to us and and
the fact that the voice written and
video consumption in our society are the
three pillars of how we consume content
the consumer entrepreneurs that I want
to spend time with are people developing
on top of voice platforms period end of
story
of our guys from over there went into an
innovation role yep and you built an
event around that theme
yes it's called if you're an innovation
roles it's just different than what I'm
used to and so I'm hitting that wall the
conservative nature of it as far as like
for example I'm generally like my roots
person to this so that's harder than the
grass that well that's a far more
interesting conversation so so I'll go
maybe in a different direction that you
may not want to hear one of my biggest
thesis is is whenever you fight the
market you lose pushing is imperative
right but if you push to a place that
doesn't map the practicality wants and
needs and you create too much friction
what I think I've done really well in my
career and when I look at other things
why I admire Amazon or others is it's
all about by the way back to Mickey ala
peas you hear innovation things of that
nature there's a level of practicality
that has to be part of it otherwise
you're just too far ahead of it so I
think you have a timing slash appetite
friction one thing I would definitely
not do is try to convince people so if
you're hitting a wall and they're
selling I would profile the nose and the
yeses and spend a lot more time with
people that look the part of yeses
I'd rather commence Jesse open- grew up
in Jersey east coast labor okay let me
see if I can get him to spend a little
bit more than he wanted to to come into
this thing that he's open to then going
to somebody who's super conservative may
have the finances but literally has made
a religious line in the sand of like
this funky junky stuff like give me you
know what I you know I'm I'm projecting
a little here but I think the key when
you're doing something new is two things
one not being so far out that it's not
consumable
and I don't sense that that's
necessarily it to everybody waste time
selling the unsellable it's not profit
driven so that's my its artistic driven
yeah that scares me that scares me it
would work if here's how things like
this theoretically tend to work I would
lose a lot of money on the most alpha
influencer in this market to take one
I'm gonna give one of these historic
families that live in the hills one of
the houses so you know that's where you
see it happen is when a tastemaker on a
macro or micro goes on to the other side
when hip-hop when when I'm just gonna
use music when P Diddy and Biggie
started talking about a lifestyle and
it's about champagne and like living
good hip-hop changed from who's the
toughest to who's the richest and it
changed the whole genre but it needed to
be somebody who's that popular to change
the conversation and I'm excited about
this I want to make this [ __ ]
what should we do like it's kind of like
we're thinking like a a brand and a
sales obviously the rack it's the
restaurant thing with every 90 not with
a at in Chattanooga every 90 days for
the group that came in during that time
like if you come in right and like so
what's this packaged dollar thing that
we can build a well-oiled machine
like that he can go find out three more
of him how do we just do it cuz it's
there like if I make a for the hundred
mile radius of this location and we
pound it we will sell guys we have think
about this from business terms you know
your P&L every like like next year fifty
days in the year we will have seven to
fourteen people in our office paint the
head for education
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're ever in Chattanooga tell her
I don't even know if I meant one second
and I like let's just give a shout out I
feel like sometimes I just get in the
mood to like give people love like it's
just a good dude
it's an amazing spot I could I know like
dude you know sick this wine is who
drinks Pinot Noir here anybody you're
gonna drink your [ __ ] this is big I'm so
pumped right now this is what I want to
say for all of us from youngest to
oldest hey everybody here's gonna live a
lot longer than they think
let's project technology you know look
you can get hit by bus in an hour I get
it but a lot longer we think this is the
biggest the inner the Internet's
maturity which is what we're living in
right now is the biggest culture shift
to our society since the printing press
so it's very hard for us to actually
grapple with what we're going through
right now because it's so much bigger
than anything we can point to so we have
no reference but it's happening and it's
an incredible area and I'm excited about
and I think if we take the offense on of
it you know it's funny we default into
demonizing technology we think writing a
note is some miraculous feat but sending
a text as kids don't talk to each other
we are missing the point of the
evolution of communication and the power
of it and I'm just I've never been more
optimistic and and I think in a micro
everybody's businesses and ambitions to
raise money for nonprofits or get a
mayor elected in this town or whatever
the hell you care about it's all gonna
happen here this is it
you got to wrap your head around it and
becoming a communicator on this device
is not about a luxury it's a necessity
over the next decade and I highly
encourage all of you to get a hell of a
lot more serious about it I think to the
point of net neutrality there's a lot of
things that people don't understand
about the issue I don't want a tollbooth
but let me give you sable who has
Verizon here anybody
great Verizon Verizon owns yeah whoo
net neutrality is just like a news
headline you're hearing about until a
year from now Yahoo is free and Google's
$25 a month it's interesting you know
there's a lot that happens now with if
if they let the service provider has
become the Tollbooth but I'm a big
believer in capitalism
okay so Comcast does this and mom Cass
does that
meanwhile google shoots a balloon in the
air and provides us all service for free
and no net neutrality issues so I think
we a lot of times you know remember when
Microsoft had to be regulated for being
monopolies no no when Walmart was too
big like we're very bad at understanding
the greatness of actual macro capitalism
and entrepreneurship
there's always innovation because people
are incentivized by the openness of the
upside
I think I think we have a real shot to
do something that everybody will talk
about forever
I really believe that I'm being dead
serious and I think that I aspire to
that you know and so I'm really excited
it's a really good feeling I really
really love the way guys love each other
and I think that foundation gives this
office unbelievable upside I've been
thinking a lot more about the long-term
aspect of this office and what we're up
to here and I really want to go deep I
really do I really want a big big build
a big successful impactful happy place
and I think when I look around it became
very obvious to me that we you know I
don't talk use the analogy of like okay
this is a nice building and this is you
know you know a brand new nice building
but the thing that makes this stick is
the steel that's behind that column that
we'll never think about in the concrete
that it's poured into the Foundation's
the [ __ ] game and within a company
that does what we do
I obviously you guys know I'm
disproportionately confident that I'll
know where to take us with our products
and services that's something I was
gifted with we will never ever lose that
game I think the thing that will make us
ultimately special is empathy I will
pound empathy down the throat of this
company next year for you to be
empathetic to each other to each other's
disciplines to what might be happening
at home or what's going on with that
client or the history of how you got
there like I transfer on a team I'm sold
that this office deploys the prime
example of empathy across the board with
the Chattanooga crew happy Holidays to
you guys leave in the comments a story
about a holiday party in your company
[Music]